this guy
uh when i heard he was up for calling in
on the day that the ravens were about to
play a big time thursday night football
game um he's one of my favorites that i
got to meet and greet and uh at nfl
network studios the old ones now
um and i loved chat with him and getting
to know him
he is a two-time super bowl champ but
guess what uh he is currently on the
all-time sax list
sitting there at eight
everybody above him is in the hall of
fame
and the one guy who's right below him
demarcus ware is first time eligible to
go the hall of fame this year he is the
man known affectionately as t sizzle
right here on the rich eisen show
mercedes-benz van phone line our friend
terrell suggs how are you doing terrell
how you been what's up race what's going
on how you been you good man i've been
hanging man you know i'm just changing
you know
chilling out okay enjoying life i love
it i love it do you miss uh tackling
people do you mistake
i do not miss tackling people i do miss
the crazy locker rooms though
in in the locker room gander
i do miss my boys but
as far as
those those man hours no i don't miss
those who is the craziest who was it was
it ray
charles uh who was the one no he was he
was the most he was he was definitely
the
the biggest leader but crazy along the
years yes um the list goes on i don't
know
bart was pretty crazy
um bart scott
yeah bart's got was pretty crazy yeah we
we had a we had a couple of crazy guys i
mean he couldn't
really line up next to us if he wasn't a
little wall okay so let's let's let's
jump into a little bit here uh
what was it like when you got in that
locker room and there's ray lewis
and what is that like when you're a
rookie and there he is and you know what
he's already built and you know what he
demands of of people what was that like
the intimidation is real and
you know his his legend
doesn't
really
do him any justice is because it was
you are playing with this for real life
larger than life player you know what i
mean it wasn't just him
you know it was it was that read also
they they kind of went hand in hand and
then you had the gentle giant j.o
who was on off inside the ball didn't
talk much didn't say much but you know
probably the hands down the best left
tackle ever played football so i mean
we had all these guys in one locker
but i guess then you get out on a field
and there's ray behind you right and you
need to do your job so he can do his and
ed can do his behind him
what sort of pressure is that for a
young kid coming off the campus at
arizona stage
tremendous pressure tremendous pressure
it's like yo just to mess this up you
know what i mean and and be with you be
where you're supposed to be you know
when you're a college kid coming out you
know you know something about you know
team sport but when you get into you
know the big show the big leagues you
got those kind of players there they
teach you about account accountability
you know what i mean and those guys
really depend on you to not only know
your stuff but to know your opponent
you know what i mean and studying your
study habits they require you to be
um a professional 24 7 not just
you know when you're at the building but
when you're off the field as well and
you know i mean i mean they act they
expected that of you because they
expected out of themselves so
i mean you don't get better teammates
than that terrell suggs here on the rich
eisen show what was it like in that
locker room when the likes went out in
the superdome for the super bowl
oh man it was just like you know it was
a lot going on especially you know roger
goodell and finding all of us and all of
that
but um
when you know we was up pretty big when
that happened i don't know he was up 28
three or 27 or something like that
something like that we were up pretty
big and the lights went out on us
all of a sudden they made this comeback
and now it's a game but you know we we
finished it out but it was
it was it was hands down the most
craziest thing i've ever been a part of
in in a in a football game well how did
you stay calm i mean how did you what
happened i mean you just go back
you know we just thought you know we
didn't think it was gonna take as long
as it did for the
for the lights to come back on but
it took like an hour or so
but we just thought you know they were
just gonna flip the switch lights come
back on we're gonna get back to this to
this rally but
it didn't happen like that it didn't
happen like that at all i just remember
harp saying stay loose stay loose and
all that
you know and ray was like yo they can't
they're not gonna stop us they're not
gonna stop but you know that was his
last game
and
we just we just wouldn't be denied they
made a run at it though
colin kaepernick they they did a a great
job of
rallying back you know what i mean and
they like scared all of us they never
took the lead though we never gave up
the lead well it was 28 to 6 when the
lights went out and so in telling the
story uh
terrell suggs you mentioned roger
goodell's name the commissioner of the
nfl's name are you like ray you think
somebody pulled the plug because the
ravens were up too big are you i mean
you know we'll lead that to the
conspiracy
well
ray's been pounding that table quite a
bit he says that a lot
i don't know i don't know you know if my
leader says it then yeah definitely uh
nfl
we were just out there having a blast
man we just had a blast you know that
was also randy moss last game too
and he was out there and it was it was
it was a real
that the story lines in that game was it
was was crazy you know what i mean you
know it was the first time two brothers
ever met that's right in a super bowl
stuff the storylines were crazy you know
what i mean and
you know we we just had fun with it we
had fun with it you know it was really
the last time all of us was together
and
i like i always say you know new orleans
is faster than me and i just remember us
riding on the bus that's like that whole
week i told all of my yo i love you
i love y'all like i couldn't say it
enough
you know
it was a really special ride terrell
suggs here on the rich eisen show what
do you think of lamar now uh are you
glad you don't have to chase him down i
mean i can't imagine what somebody in
your position
uh has to do with the quarterback that
represents your team now
man he and you know when he first he's
really playing quarterback now you know
in life so he's a little bit more
conscious you know
he he don't really think run like but
when he first went on his risk a year he
ran every time
and it was a nightmare in practice
because he was the scouting quarterback
and
i had to tell him i'm like dude
you that the quarterback is not as fast
as you you got to jog
you know what i mean if you're going to
scramble i'm not going to pull a
hamstring chasing you in practice so
but you know the the the jump that he's
made to be an nfl mvp
and just the wins he's like it's
we've never seen nothing like it so
you're saying
you're saying when lamar first got there
right
before he
gained the the role of starter midway
through his rookie season
you're saying you needed to pull the
rookie aside and say the purpose of you
running quarterback of scout team is to
mimic the person i'm supposed to be
playing against this weekend and the
person i'm playing against this weekend
is not you because there's nobody like
you you literally had to say that to
lamar jackson slow down tell him he had
the job you have to draw
were playing phillip rivers whoever we
were playing phillip rivers
you know what i mean like
come on
you know what i mean like
uh andy dalton wasn't that fast
wasn't that fast like you gotta come on
man did he listen you gotta jog did he
do did he jog then after that did he
actually jump but he was still too fast
even his jogging is that fast
he is amazing his jog is a lot of
people's top speed and it was ridiculous
yeah we like yo man you can't you can't
keep doing that yeah i mean
he is the scrambling out there he is
amazing and and you know uh
in 2019 his his mvp year he was six and
two midway through just like now he had
400 fewer passing yards than he has now
he had only about 37 more rushing yards
than he has now
and only accounts for two more
touchdowns rushing or passing than he
has now he has the same number if not
better than his year that he was the
unanimous mvp
i don't even think he's 25 yet is he 25
yet good question i've got guys who have
thankfully have google in front of them
uh yeah i think he's probably like 24.
he's 24. he's 25 yeah sizzle you're
right he's still 24. yep 24. that's
that's that's crazy
the kid hasn't even went through nfl
puberty yet
so what do you think the ravens chances
are this year what do you think as they
go tonight against the dolphins
you know the ravens they always got a
shot well i mean what i'm gonna say
they always got a shot because you know
just the culture and attitude they
always got a shot to 62 that's in the
top of their division and that's a start
you know what i mean and um
they if you know they they play how they
supposed to play they'll they'll be in
it i think i saw something if they
started today they would have
the number one seed in the in the in the
afc so you know i mean they always got a
shot what do you think of what do you
mean by culture and attitude
just that you know um in baltimore they
kind of live for november and december
football i think that's when
the the the the
you know who's for real and you kind of
know
where you stand
and you know if you're a legit contender
in that november december and
that's the football
that they we used to thrive on i'm
pretty sure they thrive on that so
one when i mentioned a two-time super
bowl champion to start this thing uh do
you have any thoughts on kansas city and
why they look so off in a way that they
never looked off you joined them
at the back end of that season i don't i
don't really have an answer for it but
you know loans 15 is that quarterback
you got one of the fastest human beings
to ever walk the planet
got to steal they still got a uh uh
iconic tight in
you know what i mean and
you know i mean they still got home
games so
as long as they got home games and and
and the shots and every game starts 0-0
and they got a shot to win it
they're going to play so i mean it's
still a long season people don't realize
that but that extra game changes
everything a lot more team you know
haven't added an extra team to the
playoffs that changes things like you're
not out
and you know what i mean and an extra
game actually puts you give you a better
chance of getting in so
um it's still a long season i don't even
think they're halfway through yet it
might be halfway through right but that
extra game is a i'm telling you it's a
game changer okay uh before i let you go
terrell suggs do you want to chime in on
the emphasis of taunting in the nfl
right now uh
what do you got for me on that know me
i'm an old school guy
i think i think it's it's a terrible
rule i think you know our game was
so good is because of the personality
the identities like just think
they would have got they would have
played ray lewis every play for tons he
jumped in a guy's face every time he hit
him
so
i think it's a rule they're gonna
eventually either lighten up
on or they're eventually gonna get rid
of it just like they did with the
celebrations you know i mean it was like
oh you can't celebrate you can't dunk
the ball over the goal
you know what i mean but then they
eventually brought that back because
they realized it was good for the game
so
um hopefully the nfl do the right thing
and ease up on it or you know eventually
just get rid of it well i mean i i don't
mind if we're taking out somebody
standing over somebody or throwing a
football at somebody you know like that
that that has no place
but yeah that has no place but when but
when you're you'll have sportsmanship
correct but but when you're now putting
such an emphasis on it that uh an
official that uh doesn't see somebody's
the front of their body but just sees
the back of somebody staring at a bench
and thinking that maybe he's saying
something and we're throwing a flag
without knowing
now we're in a totally different ball of
acts like what happened on monday and i
i can't stand that that one just
configuration you mean i think it has
too much of an outcome of the game and
you don't really want to take the
outcome of the game out of
out of the field of play
on
on a call like that so well let's do
this more often now that we're back in
touch i remember you used to come on on
ravens cam on nfl total access i had
hair you were playing football it was
great hair
look at us now look at us now baby look
at us now great to connect with you
again i would love to have you back on
if you're as much as you're up for it
terrell sucks absolutely rich you know
we love i love our chats right back at
you that's uh t sizzle the
one and only terrell suggs
currently
right now
eighth
leading sacker of all time 139
doesn't miss
putting people down on the floor
on the turf but does miss the guys in
the locker room hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here